so we have three functions here what I
want to do together is think about
whether each of these functions are even
or odd and just as a little bit of a
reminder for an even function if you
were to input negative X into the
function it's the same thing as
inputting X that F of negative x is the
same thing as f of X for an odd function
if you input negative x into the
function that's going to be the same
thing as the negative of inputting X
into the function and then if it's
neither well then neither one of these
are going to be true so let's test this
so let's do let's first look at H of X
and like always pause the video and see
if you can if you can work through this
before I do so let's just see what
happens if I try to evaluate H of
negative X so it's going to be negative
10 times negative x to the 11th power
plus negative X to the ninth power minus
negative x to the third power plus seven
times negative X well what is that going
to be equal to well negative X to the
11th power is going to be equal to the
negative of X to the 11th power because
we have an odd exponent right over here
let me just restate what I just said
so negative so negative let me just so
negative x to the third that's the same
thing that's the same thing as the
negative of X to the third we know it's
going to give you a negative value
similarly negative x to the seventh is
going to be equal to the negative of X
is seven try it out with some number
here if this was negative one negative 1
to the seventh power is the same thing
as negative times 1 to the seventh power
so let me let me write that over here so
this is going to be negative X to the
11th power this is going to be negative
X to the ninth power and here when I'm
writing this way we're going to do the
exponents
first and then put a negative in front
of it this is going to be this is going
to be negative of X to the third power
and this is just well this is just
negative x so if you have negative 10
times the negative of X to the 11th
negative times a little negative is
going to be a positive so this is going
to be positive 10 X to the 11th power
and then minus X to the 9th power minus
X to the ninth power and then you
subtract a negative x to the third so
that's going to be a positive x to the
third and then this is going to be minus
7x and notice what we have right over
here is similar to what we have up here
except all the signs are different so
this is the same thing as if I took a
negative and I multiplied it by H of X
so this is negative H of X so if I took
each of these and I multiplied it by a
negative one then I got what I just got
here which is H of negative x so we just
saw that H of negative x is equal to
negative H of X and so we know that this
is an odd this is an odd function and
one telltale signature for it is it's
made up of a bunch of odd functions we
have an odd exponent over here this is
an odd this is going to be an odd
function if it was by itself this is an
odd function if it was by itself this is
an odd function if it was by itself and
so is that an odd function by itself so
if you add up a bunch of odd functions
you're going to get an odd function all
of these have odd I have odd exponents
on them which make them odd functions so
let's think about the f of X right over
here so F of negative x well negative 7
well negative x to the sixth power you
multiply a negative six times it's going
to be a positive so that's just going to
be negative seven x to the sixth and
then plus three well negative X to the
fourth power let me don't want to skip
steps here so this is negative X to the
sixth power plus three times negative
negative x to the fourth power minus 9
times negative x squared and then we
have plus eight well negative
negative number two the six power is
going to now be a positive number so
this is going to be equal to negative
seven times the same thing as X to the
sixth plus well negative X to the fourth
the same thing as X to the fourth the
negatives all cancel out so you're gonna
have 3x to the fourth then minus this
negative x squared is the same thing as
x squared negative three squared is the
same thing as three squared just giving
an example so it's going to be negative
nine x squared the negative to your
cancel out plus eight well notice this
is the same thing as f of X so we have F
of negative x is equal to f of X so f of
X is even and once again this should not
be a surprise because it's made up of a
bunch of even functions all added
together each of these are symmetric
about the y-axis so you add them all
together you're going to get an even
function it's made up of a bunch of
terms that all have even degrees so it's
a six degree fourth degree second degree
you could view this as a zeroth degree
right over there
now let's think about G of X G of X
buried in here and you might just be
able to look at it say okay look this is
an even function there this is an even
function but this is an odd function and
this is an odd function it has a third
degree term and a first degree term so
it's a mixture of you know even an odd
function so if I so this is going to be
neither even nor odd and you could test
that out we can look at G of negative x
is going to be equal to well negative x
to the fourth is the same thing as X to
the fourth so it's going to be three X
to the fourth negative X to the third is
the negative of positive x to the third
so that's going to be that's going to be
a positive 10 X to the third that then
actually let me just write this let me
write it all out so negative x to the
fourth minus 10 times negative x to the
third power plus negative x squared
minus negative x so this is just X to
the fourth this is the negative of
positive x to the third this is the same
thing as x squared and then this will
that's just negative x
so this is going to be 3 X to the fourth
power negative 10 times the negative of
X to the 3rd is positive 10 X to the 3rd
power plus x squared and then you
subtract a negative plus X so notice
this is neither G of X it's definitely
not G of X because we swap the signs on
the two odd powered terms we swap the
signs over here but it's also not it's
also not the negative of G of X we've
only swapped signs on a few of them and
that's because we've swap signs on the
odd ones on the odd terms not on the
even terms so this one right over here
is neither even nor odd